ما تقوله إسرائيل هو أنهم
في الأساس يعفون أنفسهم من
تلك المسؤولية إذا
قُتل مدنيون بمجرد أن يطلبوا من الناس الخروج
من تلك المناطق ولكن الاستمرار في الطريقة التي
يفعلون بها أه لا
يعني بالضرورة أن الرسالة وصلت
إليهم  نحن ننشره على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي،
إنهم يسقطون منشورات تحتوي على رموز الاستجابة السريعة
التي تأخذك بعد ذلك إلى موقع ويب يحتوي على
خريطة معقدة للغاية وكما
أبلغنا على نطاق واسع طوال هذا
الصراع، كان هناك
انقطاع متكرر للتيار الكهربائي سواء كان محليًا
أو كليًا  في جميع أنحاء غزة حيث لم
يتمكن الناس من الاتصال بالإنترنت، لا يمكنهم استخدام
هواتفهم للوصول إلى الإنترنت،
وبعد ذلك حتى لو تمكنوا من ذلك،
فسوف يرون هذه الخريطة المعقدة بشكل لا يصدق
في ذلك اليوم أه إسرائيل أسقطت
منشورًا أه  في جنوب غزة حول هوناس
التي تحتوي على سورة، آية من
القرآن تشير إلى تحذير نوح
من الطوفان القادم، وكانت
غامضة إلى حد ما ولكن
يبدو أنها نوع من
التحذير المشؤوم إلى حد ما يخبر الناس في كونون  يجب
أن نخرج لأن القتال على
وشك أن يشتد وهذا بالضبط
ما رأيناه إيلاني